right a lot of good ideas out there
and i'm glad my one haven't been spoken
yet
okay um i
finished my course in 2011
i went to a country school in london
rich
which is queensland border now over
there i've met a lot of challenges i had
to be creative and
um i
i came across with through farmers
resources which inspired me so greatly
to be creative
and i made a lot of news resources which
got me recruited into a program called
excel
and the latest thing i did for excel was
regarding google drive now google drive
is so powerful let me try to sell your
product okay
absolutely nothing okay so
first of all i want you to know that
google form can be used
to create online quizzes now if you
think you know fiddling around online is
a lot of time consuming tasks no it's
not it's faster than photocopying it's
faster than cutting and pasting
now imagine
the savings for paper
okay it's a good idea okay
the idea is the fastest time i actually
created a quiz was actually five minutes
put that into your mind okay now
let's move on
you're not getting students to answer
them online in a class you actually
email
the quizzes to the students so that
students can answer them and you know
work on them look into their book do
some research at home at their own pace
now as you can see the priest was
emailed to the students all they have to
do is fill in the information
click on the buttons abc id for multiple
choice should answer questions etc and
once they press the submit button in
their email all that data gets collected
guess what even better it gets collected
in a spreadsheet online inside google
drive okay so
as you can see you can easily tell when
students make mistakes
it's all in a google spreadsheet so
whenever head teacher asks you do you
have any evidence for students learning
you can use that as evidence when you
try to come up with something to show
the parents here we go evidence
now
it gets better if you are technology
heavy like me um but it doesn't take
long to learn you can actually put some
scripting into the spreadsheet and guess
what you can email the students the
solutions
instantly right after they press the
submit button automatically done
by spreadsheet now
put up your hand if you know the power
of instant feedback
like
you don't want to go around and talk to
every single individual students like
marketing students quizzes will be time
consuming of course
with this students get the feedback
immediately
now what gets better is you can even be
like freaky you can tell when a student
submits their response sometimes when i
finish
writing my quiz and send a lot out to
the students immediately i got a
response from a student like he
filled out all the answers before i can
put the solutions up
it was amazing sometimes i get a email
and tell me that student finished their
work 12 o'clock at night
i tell myself i have to speak to that
kid
now if you have your mobile phone
synchronized to gmail
you get the email to you um along with
um the one that gets to sen gets sent to
the students okay um okay so that's how
the system works it's just brilliant uh
you don't need me to tell you about this
you know effectiveness of having
assessment in class uh you don't need me
to tell you about
how engaging students
you know respond to technology and what
have what's
um the big deal is i managed to because
it takes such a short time to create i
managed to do a quiz every single week
now
all that quizzes get saved in google
drive for you to use later on in the
next
class or you can share it amongst the
faculty or you can share account with
colleagues across the world okay now
that's the beauty of this google drive
um now total cost absolutely free it
doesn't cost a single time total time if
you are very familiar with this google
drive how to create quizzes it takes
5-20 minutes productivity i reckon is
very high
okay now
i'm not sure how much time i have left
i'll go through the little details well
google spreadsheet is also in google
drive the beauty of it is you can access
it anywhere you want on any computer i
can share it across the faculty and the
faculty members can put in their
information their data in the same
spreadsheet so you can check and compare
other students work
they provide me a record-keeping as well
now that's google drive now to create a
quiz you could create you go to form and
you fill in make sure you have them fill
in their student name and email as a
question for sure dancer
the beauty of
um
putting
images in is drag and drop because this
system allow you to just
take a screenshot of a multiple choice
question from somewhere and just drag
the file into google form and that allow
you to create a crease just like that
now i use a software called spring
hunter every time i take a screenshot
everything gets saved into a file so i
can drag and drop into google form now
multiple choice questions where do you
get them i find the new century my stats
were very small
where i came from like every single year
there's this topic test and it's most
likely multiple choice or short answer
so
i can create a quiz just like that
within five minutes screenshot
screenshot shrink shot drag and drop
send it out
so a quiz can be made within five
minutes if you're skillful um sometimes
you can be creative and create your own
questions
you can put a time
a time zone question in there and
get them to reply
via short response now the
spreadsheet doesn't automatically check
for correct solutions it simply sends
students the correct solution so they
can check it
on their own so there's lots of creative
ideas of how you can use google form to
create quizzes it's just a brilliant
idea once you finish creating the quiz
go to file go to send form
copy and paste all the student emails
which you previously prepared now if you
want to go a bit further
spreadsheet go to tools
okay go to tools and putting a script
now if you want to script
um
oops previous like but if you want the
screen go to this site put in your email
and i will send you the script for
automatic email response to students
thank you very much